did you see come in america too yes i
did oh well it wasn't
they've heard awful things okay let's
not do that let's not say that's it
well no that's what's my he's my hero
man eddie is my hero and he's
everybody's hero he killed it but
yeah i'm sure he killed it i haven't
seen it i was
like i come in america for me the first
one's cool it's not like you know you
didn't like it
no it's good but i i think that's great
it's great well life is amazing yeah
yeah
but uh it's tough to do a sequel in 2021
well it's also tough to do a sequel when
you're touching something as great
as coming that's what i'm saying like we
some things don't need a sequel yeah
like i'm thinking yeah like on breakfast
club
i think it was yesterday i listened to
them every morning charlotte they had
charlemagne was like man i we got early
release on it he's like i don't want to
say anything he's like
it felt good because i looked seeing
like arsenio hall and the whole team
back together
but it was just a bad movie he did he
was like they wrote like
they wrote it to be funny where they
should just wrote a good story but yeah
but not a good story
so then they had fans like calling in
like what's your opinion on
you know of the the new come to america
and out of whatever 50 callers not
one was like oh it's fantastic like i
was too cheesy too yeah
it was awesome well i think what
happened uh was they used the same
formula from the first movie
does that make sense yeah yeah so it's
pretty much it's kind of like uh
dumb and dumber oh yeah so when dumb and
dumber came out they were using
all of the same yeah we already made the
first one so amazing but
but the time that the first one came out
it was yeah it was
but that's like those still that still
holds up like dumb and dumb are
definitely holding no dumb and dumber
does not matter i'm talking about dumb
and dumb
the new ones it's like but when they
wrote dumb and dumber it's like it's a
good
story yeah and those guys are so funny
you're gonna find the funny in there
yeah
but now like dumb and dumber er and then
coming to america
it's like they were like oh let's write
funny instead of let's write a good
story for everybody to follow and they
had a formula yeah and they were just
replacing yep dialogue within the
formula yeah yeah
i mean they're gonna watch it oh you
should you know it's the most
it's the most streamed movie of 2021 on
any streaming platform well
over over that jamie foxx one uh seoul
oh yeah oh damn it was great well i mean
you gotta think about how many
generations is eddie murphy
i mean everyone [ __ ] with them did you
hear them do you listen to mark maron at
all do you know mark oh i love mark
merritt yeah he's so he was on mark
marin's podcast literally my favorite
podcast
he had eddie on there and uh it was
great just recent
yeah it came out like last week and uh
eddie and him talk for an hour
and he was talking about doing stand-up
he's like i haven't done stand-up
forever since my delirious special
and he's like since raw since raw and
then he was like i had all this time off
he was one of the reasons i came back
he's like because
i was making shitty movie after shitty
movie after i was getting these
razzy awards and he's like and people
forgot like
maybe they forgot i wasn't funny so i
was gonna do stand up to show these
[ __ ] like oh no i'm still funny
man
he's like i also took a break from
movies because i was just making bad
movies
yeah he was like he was like they just
weren't bad they they just weren't good
so
i was gonna come back and make good
movies which yeah come to america he
might hide again
yeah but dolomite was amazing oh yeah oh
yeah
but people hate on like i think all the
nutty professors are [ __ ] great like
brilliant all of them are great
that's the one nutty professor that he
he wished like he was like he thought he
was going to win like
yeah awards for that because of him
playing all those characters doing the
whole
dinner table family everything yeah he
should have he should have went off
there
he goes that's the one he was like it
killed him
yeah yeah that should have killed him
yeah he's still
acting yeah like like there's never
going to be an acting performance like
that ever again people try to do it
he stole that performance like there's
no way that can ever be dude located or
top
i don't know if you knew this but so um
they didn't want him to do all those
characters
really so he had to audition he goes he
goes let me do it he goes what if i
audition as the characters wow he'll
come he's like i'll come in as
each character who's going to be better
and i'll audition all the characters and
he did it and they were like
okay yeah dude you should you should
hear him on mayor because marion's
talking about how he came up and stand
up oh
16. yeah i know i know his whole
background he was on the road like with
real like vet new york comics yep and
mark's like damn it
16 he's like yeah man he's and then he's
like it happened fast for me
and then he's like but that's all i know
so at the time i just expect everything
to happen fast
and he said then someone called him uh
someone who owned like an improv or
something was like okay you know
saturday night live's looking for a
black guy you should audition
no [ __ ] it i'll go up there gets it and
then mark was like we just freaking out
he's like
again like i i was like the prodigy so
like yeah of course i got it
yeah he's like at the time i realized i
gotta listen to this he's like i didn't
realize how big of a deal it is
yeah i got the job i was like yeah of
course i got it he's saying i'm gonna do
this i'm doing first 48 you know
uh 48 hours yeah and i'm gonna do movies
like that
like chevy chase did it before trading
places
yeah beverly hills cop yeah i told you
guys i went to raw
in person i said that yeah i actually
asked you about it when uh
you know from phoenix but yeah so it's
amazing but you hear like kevin hart's
i guess eddie throws a party at his
house like once a month
pre-covered like once a week and it'd be
the funnest people
that we know of in comedy like kevin
hart was everyone was there in the comic
scene
and they said they would beg eddie to do
stand-up because he's
dominate like they said he was just he's
the finest guy in the room of course and
kevin's like dude you gotta come back
and do stand up
yeah and fight he started to do it he
had all his whole you know he's like i
probably have two hours of material
yeah and he's like but it's all notes
he's like like i haven't been able to
work it out because he was like i was
gonna go to the clubs and do it the
right way
but covet came so now you know we'll see
you know what's crazy is i i would love
to just tell eddie
that you don't even need to uh work on
it
because when he sits do you ever watch
him on a panel come on yep when he just
tells the story at the panel
like when he's on fallon or whatever
that story that gem that he says
sitting down is you got
because he's just going from the hip and
it's uh his old school story is such a
beast like
something i forget who the famous guy
was but he's saying our thing was to
like uh joke with each other like oh i
bet you won't do this
so he says he's backstage at mass square
garden with this guy forget the guy's
name famous guy
because we're backstage at a diana ross
concert and he goes eddie says to his
friend goes i bet you won't grab down or
rots his ass and he's like why would you
do this to me eddie because he has to do
it
so in the middle of performance you know
he gets on stage and they're like what
the [ __ ]
he gives her a hug and then looks at
eddie like grabs her ass
and then eddie says uh that sounded live
and it was one i forget what uh
you know that i want to rock down to
yeah
yeah
yeah so these guys have dreads and
they're all in the saturday night live
they're about to perform
and uh eddie goes hey oh i guess the guy
goes
man someone told me that the way those
black guys get dreads they put goats in
their hair
and eddie goes i dare you go ask them if
they put goat [ __ ] in their hair
he's like why would you do this to me so
he walks in the room and he says he
starts off small he's like man you guys
got cool here and all
right thank you thank you and he's like
yeah it must be really difficult to get
there
and they're like yeah you know it takes
some time he's like yeah uh someone told
me that you guys got to put goat [ __ ] in
your hair to get it like that
and they said it was like quiet and the
guy was like no man no
and then he said he looked at he goes
why'd you tell me that and then
that's funny he's yeah he's got a lot of
great stories yeah it's pretty new
he's a killer like he's killer like even
i watched his uh
it was his uh inside actor's studio
james lives
i love
especially he's just so chill and he's
gonna like he'll have a great
conversation with you
yeah and you just you just let him go
you know who is richard pryor of course
he said he met him after like not the
drug richard like when
he was going through like rehab like
when he's trying to get his life right
he said he was on a plane with him and
his album just came out
and he's and then he was getting on the
plane the story was like he uh
richard price on the plane and eddie was
like oh [ __ ] that's my hero man
so he said he had a copy on cassette of
his album went up to richard's like can
we listen to us
on the plane and he was like y'all was
he was i know who you are listen to it
so he said he was like four rows back
from richard watching him
he said richard had on was yelling going
you funny man
holy [ __ ] and then they get off the
plane
and richard's like where are you going
and he's like oh i'm going somewhere in
the hills he's like i'll give you a ride
man
and so he said he jumped in gave him a
ride there like spit game on them while
they were there
what dropped off really crazy that's an
amazing story he's got a lot of great
stories
he does all he has to do is just get up
and tell the stories man
have you ever seen him do an
impersonation it's the best impersonator
it's so
i love jay farrell i love jamie when
they do their [ __ ] i got it but i'm
telling you when eddie gets a hold of it
it's different it is it's different
it's like he embodies it i saw him do
tracy morgan for like four seconds
and i was like did he just do that have
you seen him do his brother
charlie romney amazing you know that's
how you got saturday night live
during the audition he just did a bunch
of impressions yeah because
charlie murphy told him to go do the
dude i can't do charlie right now just
do it though
please do it hey man we let me let molly
talk
[Laughter]
you see i'm setting up now it's your
turn come on just do it
come on do it just do it let's do it
charlie's watching right now
you don't have a whole lot of [ __ ] you
know charlie murphy's story that's just
dying to get out you don't want charlie
murphy
he started off in paper soldiers
[Applause]
you know charlie murphy had a brother
named eddie right
what did you say hey hey did you did you
know uh
charlie murphy what him and rogan would
tour together
they put him together and charlie just
started doing stamp everyone thinks
charlie's like a stand-up
he's not yeah really late and he got
famous off the chappelle show because
he'd tell stories
so they're like man you need to take
these stories and do a stand-up back
absolutely they put him and rogan
together
but think about wrote especially even
then rosie's been doing time for 20
years
and rogan uh you know the the headline
the the you know the the marquee would
say joe rogan and
charlie murphy yeah well charlie murphy
sometimes closed the show out but oh
yeah
he's a monster especially back then
monster monster he's like a season comic
so rogan would tell him like doug i'm
just trying to help you out you
shouldn't
go after me he's like this just from a
comic's perspective yeah
you should go then i go man like robin
was always trying to help him out
that's dope yeah they were they were
like solid yeah that's that's really
close
that's a heavy that's a heavy thing to
put on charlie at that time
monster dude you know i mean but like i
uh i could see why the promoters
thought that you know what i mean at the
time
at that time that was awesome remember
he's not doing stand-up he's telling
stories no i know hogan's come with
straight
stan oh i know it's like a different
rhythm yeah
rose like it's off man yeah and i you
should go then i go
exactly that's how it should have been
those promoters have no idea yeah and
really
like an awkward conversation but he's
like i'm literally just trying to help
you out
i'm just trying to show you man that i'm
about to uh set that stage on fire
and then you're gonna go on and you've
been doing stand up for two minutes
yeah yeah and then you're gonna burn
yeah but that yeah
sometimes that's a that's a tough pill
to swallow you know what i mean like you
know that
who you are at that time you know i mean
i deserve this spot
it's like sometimes you know you'll run
you'll come across cats that are very
humble
and and and will bow down that's why
that's why i'm so fortunate for brian
count because when i started stand up i
had training wheels because brian was on
stage with me
i'd go out and do my own [ __ ] for 10
minutes but then brian would come out
and then i have brian who who's been in
comedy for 30 years yeah 60 years
yeah and brian would set me up for
success yeah you know like i'd be like
what are we going to do and he's like
hey remember and you're just off to the
races yeah
like brian i'll see you a tag team once
oh yeah you come out together
that's great like a show but brian was
so good at like making sure
that i didn't fail yeah he'd be like oh
hey remember that time we were doing
this i'm like oh yeah cause he knows
it's a funny story that's the cool thing
about watching brian when i was coming
up is like
you know because you know when i watched
brian it was at the clubs
so you know we were all working on our
[ __ ] you know i never went on the road
with him
so one thing i noticed with him is when
uh he tried new [ __ ]
and it would bomb he would stick with it
and just let him in
yeah commit yeah and uh and make it work
and if it didn't work you didn't give a
[ __ ]
you know i mean he just goes something
else yeah and that's that's a hard thing
to learn when you're first coming up
you know when you start bombing right
away on some on an idea
you panic you know you freeze what do i
do next
yeah and then you have to like really
learn how to like sit down
well they were saying richard pryor like
one of the things eddie was saying
that's one thing that made him so
special
is when he was on the heroin all the
drugs he was so funny
but he's always been doing that in
standup so then when he got sober
eddie said whenever richard would
perform at the comedy store all the
comics
like him mooney everybody go down there
watch richard
but when he was sober he was trying to
figure it out and then marc maron was a
doorman at the time
he's like dude i've seen richard pryor
bombed like yeah
for a long time he's like but he would
stay with it he'd stick with it stick
with it stick with it
and then eventually you'd see like six
months go by and then that [ __ ] just a
[ __ ]
it's his closing bit he said he'd eat
dick for
months yeah i wouldn't give a flying
[ __ ] that's so cool i love that i love
hearing i love hearing stories are still
i mean rogan's that you know
brogan's the exact same way yeah i have
a concept and you'll see him in the main
room you know he closes out
we'll all go on before we have our bits
from the road that we know are going to
hit
we'll go on there he has all his notes
he records it
he'll go out then it might not work
those first few weeks and they're like
goddamn
bombing out there and that is like
excuse me
and then next thing you know a few
months go by and he's just a [ __ ]
killer with that
i oh your boy george um he he
what that was his first that was his
first time ever on stage yeah yeah
he was there that's the youtuber guy
with logan paul yeah yeah it was just it
was cool to
you know i offered that up to him i
don't like to tell people you know i
mean because
because he's got a huge following yeah
so my whole thing with that is uh
and i've done it before for other people
as well but i'm like if you're trying to
get into this game
like do it the do it the right way learn
the craft man don't let anyone know
you're growing up don't tell your fans
you're going up no yeah because the
minute they start paying for tickets to
come see
you they cheated yeah they're never
coming back yeah so i told them that i
go look dude my shows are already
done we don't have to worry about ticket
sales just walk up no one's got to know
you're here don't announce that you're
there yeah yeah yeah and
and have an honest crowd in front of you
yeah that way you
cause if you're going to do it right
your friend they're going to laugh at
you saying hi how much time did you give
them like man
it started with five and then what's at
nine and then it went to like 15.
it was good but yeah he like uh he just
appreciated
yeah which is like you know some people
like i feel like they when they get into
it they're like yeah i do stand-up
comedy but like
he really wanted to like be good up
there
yeah you know what i mean yeah he would
appreciate it yeah you can always ask
questions
yeah always ask questions all that like
you [ __ ] hope so
yeah like yeah but i mean he better be
that way
that's [ __ ] fine if you think about
it that's a that's a rarity i'm 100
dude if you're not appreciated like a
lot of guys getting this game and
comments right away and they you we are
not the same
yeah we're not the same [ __ ] to work on
dude yeah a lot of people told me i used
to take guys on the road right i mean i
would get like
14 sold out shows at the san jose improv
right and i have an opener for
come with me right and uh you know
there's a guy i always take the same guy
on the road right and then uh and then
at the end of the week
a tweet would go like hey man thank you
all for coming out to see me
like what it'll be a picture a picture
of him at the end probably
him no [ __ ] oh you're thinking
yeah yeah yeah like all up in the videos
he's like 14 soledad
14.
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah that was the thing about george man
he just appreciated this yeah
has he gone since huh has he been on oh
yeah he goes up but like i keep telling
him don't tell people you're on the oh
she announced it no no he doesn't
he that's the thing he listens he just
listen i i don't know the guy yeah
he's yeah really nice guy man yeah this
dude right here man he's he's fun to
told you
yeah he's fun to watch goes up and does
how about he's
selling out his own shows now yeah he
sold out kansas city improv
sold out austin that's amazing which
we're going back there
yeah yeah april 22nd tickets to be on
sale probably in the next few days but
vulkan was it volcano
gas company i got six shows there uh
april 22 to 24th
that's sick how about that when i get
off stage in the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son